[Music]
5 25 now on your monday morning ready or
not the rebuilding of i-15 at tropicana
is getting underway starting tonight and
for the next couple of weeks going to be
various overnight lane reductions hov
lane closures both directions of the 15
between trop all the way down to the 215
but you know what that's really not the
point of today's story the nevada
department of transportation is inviting
you
to a public meeting wednesday evening to
go over the entire massive project and
take your questions scheduled to start
at four wednesday afternoon in the
events center of the hampton inn that's
just south the crop west of the freeway
now the formal presentation is going to
start at 5 30 if you're interested we
can't make it it will be streamed on
ndot's facebook page so this huge
project includes completely rebuilding
trop over the freeway redoing parts of
the flyover ramp from the south 15 to
eastbound trop
even casually interested drivers and how
this is all going to work you should
consider checking out the meeting we got
the links in the online version of this
story when you visit our website
8newsnow.com click traffic then driving
you crazy buckle up drive carefully
please put down that phone join the
drive in you crazy conversation at
traffic 8 8 news now dot com